after years of trying the tech industry
is finally making robots happen from
vacuuming to mowing to serving drinks
and patrolling airports these autonomous
droids are everywhere and yes they're a
little creepy but then there's this
little guy the Gita mini it's designed
and programmed to be paired with a human
sort of like a very obedient dog full of
ones and zeros it also carries stuff for
you 20 pounds of stuff making it a proxy
backpack or kind of like a grocery bag
on Wheels if you trace gita's family
tree eventually you arrive at the Vespa
a few years ago piagio the Italian
scooter giant was looking for a product
to crack the American Market which never
really warmed up to the festival it
invested in a Boston startup called fast
forward and the Gita project was born
according to CEO Greg Lin the idea was
to Zig where other robot startups were
zagging instead of trying to replace a
human entirely they set out to augment
one the Gita like a Vespo is intended to
replace car trips but by enabling
walkable errands say going to the corner
store for a bag of dog food the bot's
good for the person and indirectly it's
good for the planet still these aren't
the droids a lot of people are looking
for
Piaggio hasn't said how many they've
sold and they've acknowledged that the
Gita at a thousand eight hundred fifty
dollars has yet to really take over a
city or a whole neighborhood the larger
opportunity lies in commercial
applications the company is now shifting
to B2B and trying to sell to airports
construction sites industrial areas and
clients like that basically anywhere you
see a cart is ripe terrain for agita
when Palling around with the Gita you're
sure to attract a whole parade of
gobsmacked onlookers that's the goal of
this thing but until the general
population is totally unimpressed
follower Bots like Vegeta still have a
lot of work to do
[Music]